[Music]
so nice to see you it's good to see you
too we miss you in new york oh yeah but
uh that's sort of well that's right i
you know i've been living here in l.a
and all of us here at the show have for
a couple of years how do you like new
york yeah i love visiting california but
what do you own a sunscreen company out
here how would you exist i
we we're not supposed to we have this in
common yes this is the palest uh talk
show this is
this is funny if you go from me to you
andy looks like ricky ricardo compared
and you're you're what norwegian stock
swedish german but i think uh a roman
soldier might have messed around with
somebody
you're i can't tan i see a freckle yeah
no no
but you and i uh not even close i'm a
long sleeve
swimming shirt do you have one of the
long sleeve sun shirts
yes there's nothing like what do i have
one i have that's all i have when i go
swimming women in a pool in a
long-sleeve sun shirt
hey ladies
everyone look at you like did that guy
fall in
that is
that is the worst suicide attempt i've
ever seen
that pool is four feet deep it's all
glamour no it is uh it is true i put on
the long sleeve shirt and the hats you
can't yeah there's not a cool sun hat
there is no cool sun yeah it's it's
brutal but you know
it shows you an example of what you will
do for your children you know i mean i
would never go outside if i didn't have
kids right
what's that for yeah
there's no tv outside
there's no reason to go out there's no
reason to go out the only window i look
out is this fake one right here
the uh you know speaking of kids you
have a you've have very long successful
marriage uh your wife who i've met
beautiful genie and and your kids are
great uh what's your what's your secret
what's the what do you think is the well
the secret is that i'm a great guy no
i'm
i i mean that's very flattering i'm uh
you know it's it is is strange as a
comedian you know touring doing theaters
and what what you know i don't like to
be away from my kids because i forget
what sleep is like so i
you know we recently did a bus tour
through america because i love america
and like andy you know
andy gets a lot of hate mail about we
went across this great land and uh we uh
i showed my kids mount rushmore i don't
know if you've ever been there anyone
been to mount rushmore
that's the most applause i've ever heard
from mount rushmore
and
not a popular not a popular well it was
it was it was pretty you know it's it's
pretty spectacular and i and i took a
look and then i realized it was just you
know foreheads carved into a mountain
and i turned to my children and i said
take a look i'm never bringing you back
here
i mean it's not to say that
is that you know the black hills of
south dakota truly are they're beautiful
they're sacred to the lakota indians
there is their most sacred land and out
of respect we carve four white guys into
a mountain
this land is sacred yeah yeah yeah we'll
be done here in a second
these fellas were all about freedom
especially the two guys that own slaves